let's go next to oh I don't know how
about Jason from Virginia who's also a
website member Jason thank you for being
a a member at joinpakman.com I
appreciate that
hey yeah Dave I've been a member for a
couple years now I always put your show
on and uh go out for a run and uh nice
you know just like following along and
appreciate everything I have kind of
like a David packman conspiracy theory
that I've been formulating uh-oh so yeah
yeah so uh oh maybe 21 you had gone to
YouTube headquarters is that right
um yeah
2021 right yeah that's when my
girlfriend got coveted on that trip yup
you're absolutely correct okay and then
like during that wasn't it on the flight
home you sat next to Alex Jones lawyer
of some sort no toots so that sitting
next to Alex Jones former lawyer was on
a different trip back from Vegas
okay because I was trying to put that
all together and then because shortly
thereafter then it was the famous Alex
Jones attack so I had just uh kind of no
and you know what the timing of it is
Alex Jones went after me before I sat
next to his former lawyer because I
talked about that with his lawyer so the
timing you just have the timing a little
bit off oh okay all right yeah I was
just sitting and reflecting on it but uh
what a Priceless story it's it really is
quite a story and there may be more
stories coming let's put it that way oh
all right well thank you so much all
right thanks Jason there's Jason just uh
you know it's sad when a good conspiracy
theory gets sort of interrupted by the
facts particularly when it would be such
an entertaining one but what can I do
let's go to Samir from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Samir welcome to the
program let's hope that the tech gods
have given you a good connection today
Samir welcome
can you hear me yes
all right David I I watched your uh your
show with that guy Patrick in Florida
Patrick Bet David yes
yeah and um in his uh during the
interview I don't think if you notice
but he totally contradicted himself
which of the hundred times are you
referring to
right right uh specifically he said well
the United States should be run like a
company
and and as a company the the United
States would do much better because you
know whatever vs excuse he came up with
but then he said that
um uh
he specifically said that
um that
he mentioned something about
millionaires
um being very powerful and then I'm
thinking like does he not realize if the
United States will run like millionaire
like a company they would eliminate
millionaires because that would be their
competition
uh I don't know that I understand if the
United States were run like a company
they would eliminate millionaires
yeah because he was saying about when
you were working at Circuit City that
um the Circuit City came in and changed
the policy and got rid of all the eye
paying people and kept all the
low-paying people yeah and that he went
uh socialism for that I don't know how
he blamed socialism but he blamed
socialism with that and then he said
well the United States should be run
like a company like Circuit City well if
the United States were very much a
company like Circuit City and Circuit
City got rid of all of their high-paying
people right wouldn't the United States
then get rid of all the Millionaires and
billionaires but he said that it was
wrong to do that so no I don't think no
I don't listen here's the thing Samir
maybe I'm just having trouble following
this but but here's what I would say
you're doing something that's really
difficult which is you're trying to
analogize provide context and find the
internal logic of things that make no
sense whatsoever and that can be really
difficult to do because a lot of the
stuff that Patrick said during the
interview made no sense and so while
it's a it's a worthwhile attempt to make
it's really tough to make sense and even
analogize the things he said because
they were so nonsensical and I came away
as confused by it as it sounds like you
did
um my next my last question is if um if
Trump were to run third party do you
think
um it would be helpful if Bernie ran
third party or helpful to who
uh the Democrats or for Bernie no if
Bernie ran third party he would take
votes from the Democratic nominee and
might end up uh leading to the
Democratic nominee losing that's why I
hope Trump does run third party
I see I see okay well thank you for
taking my call uh David I love your show
and I watch it all the time thank you
Samir from Pittsburgh very much
appreciate it great to hear from you